oh so fun what we just did
hey guys I'm Ryan right and Elissa what
I'm implying you know what really
happened
we're gonna watch a trailer for unbroken
that's what she called me and I'm pretty
sure is like an Angelina Jolie film or
something I love her yeah and I think
the Coen brothers are but I don't know
my facts about this I don't know if he's
starring here or something but you know
because she directs now what she's a
director she directed a movie like last
year or two years ago really yeah I got
like a nomination for something no no
I'm really I'm really good at knowing my
facts you gotta keep up with movie
history I do I like I like it
no no any time a female gets an
opportunity to make a movie that is an
accomplishment what does that mean
that's just woman you know don't you
usually are not capable of doing that
but woman find a way to well over that
extra oh they're right oh okay I mean
you should feel privileged that we allow
you to even participate as an actress
you know just because we need other
genders but really I mean if people
would accept male actors as actresses
alone we wouldn't really need you guys
this is the way the business really is
people to thoughts that's all right I
don't even know how I did it's not
sexist if you're just speaking the truth
[Music]
keep going the way you're going end up
as a bum on the street
you train you fight harder than those
other guys and you win
you can take it you can make it
you can do this look you just gotta
believe you can does does
I do
you're a moment of pain with the
Lifetime award
we're gonna die I'm not dying
Oh mr. Louie talking I'm now interned in
a Tokyo prisoner of war camp I can't say
this this man used to do anything
[Music]
if you can be through this I swear I'll
dedicate my whole life to
I can take it I can make
get down dude Ruxin sure
I've had goosebumps for like the past
minute or so I looks inspired Wow I'm
probably gonna see that opening day
Christmas yeah I will literally take
time and go see that what about Sunday
service mass are you outweighing Jesus
movie I will see this I will make time
to see this Wow no it does look really
good and it's from the Coen brothers
wrote it which is awesome and I don't
know like Angelina Jolie seems like you
know she she she knows her stuff it's
surprisingly Olien a woman knows her
stuff a woman I saw but I mean true
stories true stories always get me
regardless of what it is this looks like
you could be my new favorite wow that's
a bold statement there's a lot of true
stories out there yeah I know I mean
they're all inspirational and wonderful
but this looks like a hard movie to sit
there to be honest like I feel like
watching this guy go from like you know
tough upbringing - champion - hey your
life is gonna get [ __ ] for a while
yeah this is just so agonizing but the
kind of character he is seems really
intriguing to me like someone who just
never you know backs down I feel like
after seeing this you're gonna come out
of it just appreciating life so much
yeah all the actors look awesome no they
all do ever that man guy is looks
incredible he looks like he's gonna get
an Oscar nomination oh that movie has
like all over everything about
everything about it is this yeah yeah
thanks for letting us know about that
trailer so wonderful yeah
and if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe at the top button and you can
subscribe to Alyssa's channel right here
I know you're silly
you're silly and you just can't get
enough of yourself I don't think before
I do things I know that's bad that has
gotten me into a lot of trouble
I'm telling you multiple arrests guys
the battery's gonna die of course so I
have to do some shout outs what best
shout outs marques Rogers hey what's up
brother
I do enjoy your videos you are awesome
can I get a shout out man that would
make my day sweet dude
sweet I'm about to make your day
Roger sorry yeah mr. Rogers or are you
Captain America one of the two oh I got
to know which eye maybe you're a
combination maybe he's like Captain
America who likes to communicate to
children they wear sweaters and wear
sweaters yeah he's like the really buff
version of this it's probably what he is
probably see that I can see that yeah
especially me his office thumbnail yeah
creep who works out all this time and
then spends all those muscles around
kids hey neighbor
Joseph the hon Oh give me a damn
shoutout Ryan I love you no homo anyways
I hope to hear my shoutout of good luck
well I cannot believe you said no homo
because I say yes homo let's do this
right now I love you too whatever get
the feelin thing out of the way let's
bone what do you look for why did you
wish it look that concerns me
you know look you know I'm gonna get
lucky he says can't say hi to list it
for me hi oh wow you didn't even read
that no I didn't care to make the
spotlight be on you at all
damn this is gonna be a thing with him
and I know you're included and now it's
like one attention with Justin myself oh
go for it here no no happen now I feel
better I feel like an [ __ ] yeah make
you look like an [ __ ] in front of
Joseph you're back you
you talk to you don't get the [ __ ] back
here no no the battery's gonna die I
talked to Joe said Joseph I [ __ ] love
you you happy now yeah come on sit back
down now I'm happy
thank you your fault Joseph we are
having a divorce
Roy Diaz hey I'm new to this channel
just subscribe this morning I was like
five or six days ago and I think this
show is freaking kick-ass and it's so
badass ten out of ten best Channy Channy
do you meant channel but he put Chani
ever better we should take a Chandler
Bing I've I've been watching your videos
all day hope the best for your channel I
would like a shout out to to show my to
show off my appreciation for this
channel we're all right Diaz
I'm glad you subscribe recently thanks
for saying we want to like the coolest
channels gave us a 10 out of 10 that's a
high score times higher than 10 no no
boy a top the top hat you guys remember
that commercial Roy Roy Roy Roy Roy Roy
Roy Roy Roy Roy is a parody of the tiger
it's the wrong song no was it you're
playing white wedding that was an eye of
the tiger fruit again no yeah it's I had
the tiger but with Roy as it come on Roy
you should comment because I want to
know do you think that was eye of the
tiger or not cuz I'm not gonna do it
again but you should tell him that it
was Roy boy thanks to have a dildo toy
but it in his butthole so he thinks of a
girl with the strap on doing you